we talked about crafting a scene mm-hmm
some tips on you know just sort of
starting out crap I've seen somebody
let's suppose they want to document
someone sitting alone in a restaurant
they want to be there alone they want to
write maybe they're looking for
inspiration right well the first thing
that I always want to teach about scenes
is that scenes are many stories they're
a tiny little story and just like a
story you got to think about a beginning
middle and end for a story you got to be
thinking about the point of that story
so what is the point of that scene and
usually because you want to make it
engaging you want to have some kind of
conflict in the scene so that's why you
usually scenes about one person don't
really work that much because okay
you're born about what's the conflict
unless you're talking about a character
who wants to go up the mountain and
struggles to get there okay there's
conflict there but most things are about
two people and they're usually just like
in a story about somebody wanting
something and having difficulty getting
it right there's your conflict right
there goal and obstacle Aaron Sorkin
likes to say intention and obstacle
right he doesn't started seeing unless
he knows the intention of the character
and the obstacle to that intention once
he knows those two things he can start a
scene so that's the basic type of it and
because there are many stories always
found that when I want to analyze a
scene a well-written scene that it it is
structure structured like a story
there's three X to it does it begin a
millon end and therefore there's two
turning points in the scene rising
tension a climax a resolution and it's
fascinating to seeing you know two three
three minutes scene how you know and
only for the well-written scenes there
are scenes that you watch and you go
okay you know but there are some in
movies we have great scenes and those
scenes are usually full stories in that
scene so that's my advice for that
you